so if you doubled Revenue across all of
these you'd already be at five and
that's probably about 6 months of work
yeah yeah so this is Raymond he's a
chiropractor does $5 million a year and
this is Alex I'm an investor and I make
all the money that I have a golden share
with diamonds that I sit on at bed and I
just count how much money I have and the
point of today is I'm going to try and
help Raymond take his chain to the next
level hey Alex uh my name is Raymond
coer I'm the founder of Kyo first of
Washington so just a little bit above my
business uh we currently have six brick
and mortar locations trilling 12 months
Revenue 5.2 million uh you better have
around roughly 1.2 million and our net
profit is about 23% do you buy those or
did you open up uh organic so far I've
bought all of them oh really okay yeah
but I think moving forward we're going
to change our strategy a little bit so
overall the company's doing well 5.2
million 23% margin healthy I was curious
whether he opened them organically or he
bought them because there's basically
two big expansion strategy either buy or
you build and so he chose a buy strategy
that initial kind of sorting told me
okay these are the types of questions
and problems I need to look out for as
he goes through the rest of the
presentation so what's the goal my
three-year goal is to try to get to $5
million Eva um I want to try to build a
business that can run individually but
then I also want to entertain um selling
to an Institutional buyer so this is
very much a prity what we talk about so
when someone says they're trying to
build it to sell it versus build it to
keep it I see both of those as basically
the same path it just shows how much
they want to work like super longterm
either way all paths lead to building a
better business so who do you help
specifically our key demographic that we
help is 35 to 65y old men and women uh
that have some kind of condition that we
can help with whether it's pain
discomfort or lots of movement insurance
or cash we're about 75% Insurance oh
interesting okay how do you help them so
the way we help them is uh when when
someone comes into our office uh we'll
design a custom treatment plant for them
that might be over a period of 60 to 90
days uh it might include chiropactic
rehab and spinal decompression right so
spinal decompression kind of
differentiates us from a lot of our
competitors because it's a niche service
that we offer um for people that have
disc related injuries is that like
stretching people out kind of thing yeah
okay exactly well how do you make money
our offer so basically on the front end
uh we offer a free consultation so then
when the patient comes in our packages
can range from 2400 to 3600 uh over a 60
to 90day period we're primarily a
reoccurring Revenue model mhm and
roughly one out of every seven of our
patients they come in for a larger case
value so like a car accident or work
injury might be worth up to $10,000 well
right off the bat I think the reason
that he's been able to expand is that
making a decent amount of money and so
typical you know chiropractors who don't
know business will sell one crack at the
back at a time uh whereas he's already
selling High ticket packages which is
the right direction to go for you know a
premium service and he obviously has a
super premium with this whole kind of
insurance $10,000 thing and so it's like
right off the bat his price points are
right what's what's advertising how do
you find him for paid advertising the
number one is Facebook ads so we spend
about 1,000 bucks per location on that
uh the second one is Google ads so we're
spending roughly 500 to a th000 per
month on on each location okay got it uh
so what's sales velocity how many do you
sell per month on average we're we're
getting about 35 leads uh per month um
and out of the 35 we have 28 that
show okay it's pretty good and so we
have a show rate about 80% that's great
um and our closing rate is about 71% so
total sales probably roughly around 20
cool solid numbers so right off the bat
Raymond's got really strong show rates
exceptionally strong close rates and
mind you this is one location so we'll
see if that's system one which then on
some part of my mind I'm like okay when
you have super high close rates like
that we might need to bump prices like
it just shows that the market is willing
to spend more and so for me like I would
say healthy close rate percentage is
usually like 30 to 40% that's kind of
like usually where you find The Sweet
Spot of price versus number of units
sold not always but that tends to be
like rule of thumb but by and large it
shows that he knows how to get people to
shop and he knows how to close what's
stay in the way what's the problem if I
were to to uh prioritize my constraints
what I think they are uh number one I
would say is probably lead flow I think
that we could do better in that
department it's not consistent okay when
I had one location it was really easy to
predict that and to to change the
outcome pretty quickly but as we've
scaled i' I'm having a tougher and
tougher time to um you know scale the
marketing what Raven's dealing with is
super common when you go from one
location to multiple especially if it's
purchased let alone you know organically
grown because usually I call it founder
magic or owner magic it's like if you
have one location it's like your thumb
print's on it like your heartbeats on it
everybody knows you they they kind of
grw up with you everyone kind of knows
your Vibe you have old customers who
remember you and so it's like always
going to be special and different than
everyone that you open after that
because you're typically just not nearly
as entrenched second one would be like
our sales infrastructure because we are
75% insurance-based there's so many
different plans out there right so we
have to when the patient comes in we
have to determine what kind of insurance
they have by verifying it and then make
a customized plan based off of that so
if there's a way to to uh streamline
that into one day I think it'll be much
more effective for us what I personally
practiced I was able to do it in one day
but I'm having I'm having a tough time
training my doctors to be able to do
that okay and then uh people operations
people operation so obviously when I had
one location it was really easy to
control the standard right uh but as we
expand it's harder and harder to have
that same
standard okay so let's see the numbers
so going over the numbers again so top
line revenue 5.2 million last fall
months profit 1.2 net margin is about
23% okay um our CAC is about 700 our
lifetime value is 3,400 so that's 4.8
to1 um LTB to co ratio uh marketing
spend we're spending about 1,500 to
2,000 per location right now the sh
rate's 80% close rate 71% and our annual
ad spend on marketing is about 110,000
so right off the bat obviously the
numbers are really strong the amount
that he's spending per location seems
low given how much money he's making so
I think there's probably opportunity
there but I'm just very curious how it
actually breaks down between locations
because that'll probably give us more
insight huh okay do you have any
anything broken out between channels
between Facebook and Google so this is
our our Facebook data um I was able to
put together like our our 12-month uh
numbers for all the clinics for as okay
and then for as far as the the challenge
that we have is because we're Insurance
based we don't get paid for like 30 60
90 days after so I had to go back and I
picked Q2 for three clinics yeah yeah
okay um so these are the numbers for for
uh for those three clinics in quarter do
so looking at this whole sheet I scanned
it and then the bottom where you can see
Q2 there it's Capitol Hill Everett and
Kent and so Kent you see an eight Raz
there so that was really strong the
lowest CAC by a decent margin and so I
wanted to understand whether that was a
performance thing or like it just costs
less because of a marketpl cost per
impression cpms are lower there there
might just be more people I wanted to
double click into that to figure out why
that one's doing so much better than the
others okay so why is Kent so much
better is the dock there different than
the other docks they're about the no's
he's he's good but he's he's about the
same I I would say that culture of that
team is is really good I think that's
one thing that stands out cuz cuz CAC is
half of Capitol Hill right you're
getting more LTV and lower CAC can't
right is it that the people that are
coming cuz it's insurance so is it that
they're like filling better like what
like how how could they get LTV to be so
much higher do you have any other data
that's you collected together yeah so
this are from Google AdWords well these
obviously do significantly better than
your Facebook ads yeah for sure
interesting so right off the bat look
all the way to the right row ad means
return on ad spend so you see 12 to1 24
to1 9:1 I'm seeing really strong roow
eyes here and so I'm thinking okay so if
I have a machine that I can put a dollar
in and get $24 back out I want to put as
much money in that machine as seemly
possible and so that's why my next
question I'm asking how much more can
can we spend here this is obviously a
profitable channel are you maxed out on
spend here uh I don't think I am the I
work with a a third party company on
this and and I basically go off their
recommendations okay I personally would
love to spend more obviously on this
because the return so high yeah um and
these people are in you know immediate
need of help yeah so they're much easier
the or case acceptance goes up much
higher with these patients High intent
yeah really good well I mean shoot this
is this is the most promising part so if
you think about people's willingness to
pay being proportion to their spending
power and the pain that they're
experiencing with it now he literally
has people in pain and so when you have
someone who's being Interruption based I
means like they're just scrolling around
and they see an ad they're probably not
as in pain as somebody who's like ow I
just did something to my back they're on
Google they're searching for a solution
immediately so the intenses are
completely different or rather they're
significantly stronger with people that
are actually looking for the solution
and so I would wager that those people
buy faster they buy bigger tickets and
we'll see if that's true walk walk me
through the sales process so day one
patient comes in we do a consultation we
take X-rays we'll do an exam and
actually start me from click to close so
the person clicks on is Google is
basically the sales process for Google
ads different than sales process for
meta or how's it how's it flow for you
yeah so Google they will call directly
into our we have a centralized uh call
center that we have so they'll call in
Click to call is the app click to call
or click to schedule on our they go to
our landing page okay so click a call or
or or they self book got it so then they
they talk to a rep that's centralized
that rep does some sort of Discovery
call do they look at their insurance at
that point on the call they don't but
that's the thing I'm thinking of adding
in so we can get on top of that so they
they do some sort of Discovery they're
currently not doing insurance on the
call yep all right so then they do what
so then they schedule them uh the the
next available time we try to get them
in same day or next day right away so
some people call and then they book them
and the people who self schedu just book
directly exactly and then what's the
what's the kind of like reminder
sequence there to make sure that cuz you
have really good shop rates yeah so we
do uh three text messages and then we do
a pH call uh if if we uh if they don't
respond to text message do a phone call
the night before to confirm we'll do
another one like uh you know 2 hours
before their appointment So Raven is
describing what appears to be very
boring work but is one of the biggest
levers that I look at that is often huge
holes of revenue for most small
businesses that they simply just don't
work their leads either well enough fast
enough or hard enough they're not
responding to them quickly they're not
personalizing the reach outs they're not
doing it multiple times and they're not
doing it in a timely fashion relative to
when they're coming in and so he clearly
had a system for for work leads like we
text him these three times this and we
do this and so as soon as someone
demonstrates that I'm like okay there's
probably not immediate holes in Ling
fruit there and his numbers kind of
supported that said differently when you
see 80% show rates you've got somebody
who knows how to work leads okay so
three reminders and call if they have
not confirmed their and followup call as
well if they didn't pick up the first
call or the other ones and then if
someone doesn't hit any of those five do
you pull them off the calendar we don't
pull them off the calendar but we we
kind of expect them not to just like
double book kind of yeah exactly okay
yep okay so then they come in so they
show up to the appointment now what they
come in for their appointment uh we'll
we'll do a consultation so we have a
patient coordinator that does it that
gets the preliminary data it's like an
assessment yep ex like movement like
move here does that hurt that kind of
thing like Z where you have pain kind of
like half closer framework okay so like
so they'll do the first half of that on
there and then uh then we'll take uh
x-rays we'll do an exam and then we'll
tell the patient that hey we need to
process these films or these X-rays and
then can we need to get you back in
tomorrow so we can go over the results
of the X-ray yeah that's where Ling
people yeah that'ss okay so then we'll
release them for we we'll still do
treatment that day we'll do a light
treatment and then we'll have them come
back the next day and by then by then
we'll have everything verified and then
we'll have a customized plan for them
and then we'll present the fin can you
walk me through the ad funnel with the
uh Facebook ads we have a video ad out
there do you have ads live right now
yeah can you um pull up Facebook ads
Library we're going to pull them up and
we're going to we're going to see it
we're going to see we're going to see
for ourselves all right so we have
different creative it looks like it's
the same copy
all right so I think there's probably
just some work that could just happen on
the actual ads themselves like I think
you could have a clear call out and the
first line I would probably separate the
call outs so it's like atten ever in
surrounding areas so inste areas I would
go to like residents or something like
or people basically combine the two
where as chronic back pain doesn't have
to be life sentence attention efforts
for your uh so be like attention ort
like residents with back pain that
combines both lines punch you put two
Asters on either side it's like okay
that's what it is and you're putting
proof first and I probably wouldn't he
I'd probably lead with a question which
would be like are you so either I would
lead with a question that' be some sort
of like more specific pain or I would
lead with the offer and then have the
proof of why they should believe that I
can help them after they've seen the
offer cuz like it took us all the way
down to actually see what the offer was
got it in the headline if you scroll all
the way down Michael avoid surgery try
spinal and decompression I would
probably just put like the offer there
so it's just like a restatement like
free spinal uh decompression but $99
value whatever something like like
that's what I would what I would put
there there's a lot of words and I think
you could probably get just like I
combined the first the headline and the
excent into just like attention Everett
residence with back pain right it's like
boom we got that and then it's like
you'd be amazed at how much like just
changing tweaking the headline probably
compressing the copy into a handful of
bullets it's like do you struggle with
boom boom boom boom and you probably
tried boom boom boom boom but there's a
better way this is how we do it we've
helped this many people for limited time
we're doing X Z and I think I think that
would probably work well I cannot
guarantee availability we commodate 10
vouchers ofation schedule I do like that
could probably be compressed okay like
we can only we can only see 10 new
patients per week right scheduling
availability is first come first serve
for this treatment done so I'm walking
Raymond through some improvements to his
ads and I wrote a book on advertising
and in the PID ad section the first part
of a re ad is a call out right is
getting people to notice the most
important the ad right that's that's
what this is and so the call out is
whatever you do to get the attention of
your audience and so there's kind of
four ways that I like to do it and the
way that I'm presenting for him here is
a yes question right which is like it's
almost implied so we're saying this
audience of people which is local area
and then the like do you have back pain
or who have back pain is kind of an
implied yes and then we're leading with
that for the call out which is the most
important part of every ad it's the only
thing most people are going to read so
once you have to call out I use a what
who win framework when I'm thinking
through ad copy and so he's talking
about like avoid surgery so this is
opposite nightmare scenario right and so
you can basically construct your ads by
put piecing these Parts together in the
ad copy and then obviously we want to
have the offer very clear when we get to
the offer section that's where we need
to tell them what to do next which is
kind of the last part of the app one of
the reasons I love doing these is that I
get to take some of the experience that
I've had from years of work and actually
just help other people out and so one I
had a chain of six locations so I had to
work leads and get people to show up all
the time and write ads to get people to
do that and then secondarily we had a
licensing business that licensed to
thousands of brick and mortar locations
and so I had to solve these problems at
scale across many different markets and
so the nice thing is the patterns are
the same and you just have to execute
them and so I'm glad that I could CH
let's go to schedule
appointment uh
Kent okay so we just go straight to it
straight to the booking okay I would see
most of our patient schedule like that
versus call there's a couple of things
that I think we can go over in terms of
sales process lead magnets things like
that honestly I think a big part of it
that's not up here is the Ops in this
type of business it's so operation heavy
in terms of like kind operational
excellence I had a hunch that if he has
the same model at all these locations
and some of the locations aren't
profitable and some of them are the
biggest lever is going to be the people
who are actually running the system so I
have to be really particular about what
recommendations I'm going to make if
there's very weak Ops and execution
behind it and so one it's going to limit
the things that I'm going to do and
change the priorities of what I'm going
to recommend and so a lot of times
business owners are like oh I need to
change my strategy when the reality is
that like the team's just not good
enough and need to focus on the team
rather than the model you absolutely can
run a 10 to1 15 to1 you know uh row well
you're already doing on Google but you
can do that on Facebook as well um if
the offer is right and so right now the
offer is like there really isn't one
let's just like try this thing um it
doesn't even say free once you come over
here and then we'll we'll walk through
game plan cool cool yep all right let's
on there's inconsistent lead flow
there's the sales process that I want to
look at I think the discovery process
need something need a better front-end
offer increase ey spend so those are
those are the really tactical things
that I'll walk through I think that
we're going to look at me magnet I think
this needs to be
better for
ads let offer is number one uh number
two is yeah
copy number three I think we're going to
go I think the
um Disco process disco dancing the
discovery all right number four
[Music]
process do you have financing oh no you
don't have financing because you're
Insurance uh we do we do so the
decompression is cash so we do offer
financing okay do you you have a third
party y okay cool then I I W so Raymond
has obviously he's got a successful
business he's doing 5 million Top Line
1.3 bottom line so he's not he's not
doing he's not doing bad and so a lot of
my questions were probing questions to
see if there was lwh hanging fruit that
already exist in the business that we
could kind of tweak and immediately
increase the profit and revenue of the
business and so these are the kind of
holes that from asking the questions
like oh we can improve something here we
can improve something there sometimes I
asked and you I was like no that's good
you got it all right and move on to the
next thing and so to be clear it's not
like I'm trying to say like he has all
these things wrong he's making money's
he's making more than a million dollars
a year like he's obviously good at
business and so I'm just trying to find
the things that I think I can add value
that are ideally low operational risk
for him to execute Raymond's actually on
level six which is all the way over
there my arm's not that long of the
scaling road map he's at 20 to 49
employees right between all of his
locations and to get to 50 he has to do
some of these steps now if we're looking
at the constraints of his business we
can see here that he's having this sales
issue so what sales issues occur at
level six well closing efficiency on
core product drops becomes inconsistent
refunds go down but so do closes and so
he's in this situation right now just
right out of the book I'm telling you
like we spent a long time on this and
businesses behave in patterns and so to
graduate he has to install Better sales
training individual coaching and a team
Cadence for making sure that they
operating at kpi or above so key
performance indicator kpi and so this is
what he has to do at this level and if
you're a business owner and you are
curious what stage you're at and what
things are kind of plaguing you well you
probably know your problems but how to
graduate to the next level and how to
solve them this scaling road map is
totally free and it's personalized to
you so you can go to acquisition. comom
roadmap just type in your business info
and we will send you the road the the
stage that is specific to you across all
eight functions of the business so
product marketing sales customer service
it recruiting HR and finance you'll have
all the problems and the solutions to
get the next level it's one of the most
valuable things I can give you it's
absolutely free go check it out and if
you by the way want to have us take a
look at your business uh on the thank
you page you can book a call you can
come out to our headquarters and our
team would uh love to kind of do what we
do here uh with
you okay so we're going to start let's
actually you know that's actually not a
bad not not a bad order okay so um
starting with the lead magga I think
that offering
$19 $29 somewhere in there first consult
or free x-ray or something to that
extent would probably go way better um
and I do like especially for your your
type of business to do a low ticket and
so it's something like this so be like
$29 uh
x-ray you know plus you know
assessment blah blah blah and the reason
I like this is because you get the
credit card on the phone okay and even
though it's an insurance thing it's like
Y no worries we just put a card down
just for for show rate obviously we have
a doctor who's going to be there we to
make sure that you're going to show
right and the thing is that if we build
them the 29 then the likelihood show up
is super high and this is literally just
to take show up rates to like basically
100% so then and this is over the phone
so this you do that's a phone I did this
in front of some gen Z kids and they're
like What's that like Jesus all right
you'll recognize it so we do this now
when they walk in the door okay so this
is going to be a little bit of a
departure okay yeah so they walk in the
door and when you um and I think the
reason that you probably sold better
obviously you're better at sales than
probably your your docs are but if you
think about how sales works so sales you
want to sell at the point of greatest
pain not the point of greatest
satisfaction so let's say to be a normal
person they're right at the middle of
this line right now they're they're
having a bad day because now they're in
pain right then all of a sudden they get
something fixed now they're even better
than normal if you're a Salesman where
do you sell do you sell when they're
here when they're in pain or do you sell
here when they're super happy at the
point of greatest satisfaction so do you
sell it point of greatest deprivation or
point of greatest satisfaction AKA pain
or value where do you
sell here so if I let's say you walk
into my restaurant all right and you're
starving and I say hey here's a steak
and you eat the steak and then after you
eat the steak I say hey how was the
steak you say oh my God was the best
steak of my life amazing and I say great
would you like another steak you might
be like I mean no but I mean hey the
steak was great great like I'm I'm not
saying the steak was bad I'm like why
don't you want to buy another steak you
said it was so good why don't you want
to buy another steak does this sound
familiar cuz I hear some sales calls
from businesses like well if it was good
then why aren't you buying more because
you're selling at the wrong time now
let's play the let's play the play the
tape back you walk to the restaurant
you're starving I say hey how hungry are
you you say I'm starving and I say cool
you want two staks you probably be like
hell yeah I want two staks I'm starving
and then I sell you two stakes you sell
at the point in greatest pain not the
point of greatest satisfaction now
here's where it gets tricky
sometimes the point of greatest
satisfaction for one thing becomes the
point of greatest pain for another so if
all of a sudden I help you make more
money for example then all of a sudden
you have a new problem which is you have
taxes and then I say hey with all that
extra money that you made I can
introduce you to somebody who can help
you with your taxes do you want that yes
and so where people canate this in terms
of ORD is you have to make sure that if
you're doing an upsell at the point of
greatest satisfaction it's opening the
loop of pain for the next problem that
you're going to solve through your next
product and so it's kind of the same
thing here where people are literally
coming in pain ideally what I would want
to do is we take the assessment instead
of doing the treatment then I want to
sell the package got it then if you want
if they have time they can do it or they
can come back tomorrow and get their
first treatment got it so it's the same
time scale we just move the order around
because like I mean I I've been this
patient so like I go go to the
caropractor they do some thing I'm in
pain they adjust my back and then
they're like hey uh come back for this
but I was like I know I'm good like you
you fixed it I'm great totally right and
then they're like but it's not a
long-term solution and I'm like good
enough for me you know like I I'm out
and so that might be an immediate like
15 you know 10 to 15% boost in sales so
like that's number one but the thing is
is that I think that your close rates
are going to go up so one is like you're
losing some on the drop off right but I
think close rates will go up and like
when you're in pain your desire for a
more like all the desire is there in
that moment and we're emotions there
we're missing it hey guys this channel I
make for you business owners this is all
I do every day this is what I love I'm
so excited about this new series and so
if you have other business owner friends
that could benefit from some of the
tactics because these tactics work
across lots of different Industries not
just chiropractors right it would mean
the world to me if you just put into a
text and you text it to them or you
share it to them in a DM CU It
ultimately helps more businesses get
better and I believe in private
Enterprise and I think that's how the
world gets saved no one else is coming
for us all right back to the video I
always had this rule at least like with
Fitness is like when someone walks in
the door first thing I want them to do
is expand the gap of where they are
where they want to be so I'd have
everybody hop on the scale the amount of
people like oh I don't want to hop on
this like I know I'm like get on the
scale we got to know where it's just a
number we got to know where we're at Mak
sense and so it's the same idea with
this got it okay so uh lead mag in terms
of off- ride do you think this would be
good this will increase show up rates
overall getting somebody to get a $29
credit card purchased with fund is like
not hard um they do that that secures
their spot then when they come in we do
um same day sale
mhm now what has been the issue with the
docs making this sale like you said they
struggled with this so there's two
elements you said there was insur like
some insurance stuff there so what
what's the issue here yeah so the issue
is uh patient comes in and then uh we
have to verify their benefits so there's
there's like 20 different insurances and
and every patient has a different like
coverage or whatever right yeah so then
we got to we have to we have to make our
uh treatment plan then take out whatever
the insurance covers and then they pay
the their co-pay Co TRS so just doing
that process um I think when they're on
the floor seeing patience and then
having to switch gears and uh do the
math of like what this you know here's
my recommendations here's you know all
that I think that part kind of stresses
them out how much of it is templated lot
most of it like as far as the so we have
we know that someone has Blue crossby
Shield so whatever yeah yeah it's all
exhaust BR you we can punch in number we
have financial calculator for that so
question so someone call so basically
there's two spots that we can put this
this process so either we can do it on
the phone right with the go yeah or we
can do it the moment they walk in the
door so it would work like this so
someone walks in and say hey do you have
your ID on you I just want to confirm
your appointment yes I'm Sarah cool
great do you have your insurance card on
you yeah and so you asked that but that
way we can get the templates already
like ready to go so that then the doc
goes and then he leaves them in there
and says cool let me get the x-rays and
then he comes in with the x-rays and
with a template for their specific
insurance totally and then you can just
match them and just do the sale yeah so
the issue is like some of those some of
those so I centralized where they verify
those benefits right um some of them
could take like 30 minutes to an hour to
so if that's that's the okay so then we
have to do it with the phone yeah I
agree so what we're trying to do here is
we're trying to decrease the friction
associated with them giving us money and
so there are three major levers to
providing value the the fourth is
obviously the dream outcome that they
want to they have to want what you're
what you're selling right but the other
three correspond to the risk aka the
perceived likely of achievement how long
they have to wait and what they got to
do that they don't want to do or they
got to stop doing that they do want to
do AKA ease or difficulty so you want it
to be easy you want it to be fast you
want it to be risk-free what we're doing
here is saying okay well he had this big
delay in the process that people had to
wait another day in order to get the
solution presented to them and so
wouldn't it be better if we could just
have that happen prior to them coming in
so that from a speed perspective and a
friction perspective they don't have to
do anything besides say yes and then we
can get we can get paid and they can get
helped and for those who are curious
that was the value equation chapter in
the $100 million offers book The $29
gets in the way then we can still just
do the it's like a you can either do a
free offer like free x-ray free
assessment whatever just if that's an
issue I mean personal preference get the
credit card and the insurance card yeah
over the phone if it seems like a
training issue then I would prioritize
the insurance card but then that way
it's like you already have everything
they're pre-loaded and so then they can
come out after the x-rays get it printed
out from the scheduler the front desk
and I mean shoot the morning of add
theop print all the print all the the
packets out for everyone and then the
doc gets them in the clipboard when they
walk in the door perfect yeah I mean you
think that would work I I think so okay
um and then if they ask like hey why do
you need my insurance I thought it's $9
bucks then we'll say like hey just in
case the doctor thinks he can help you
that's want to know while your insurance
yeah better I'll give you a different
one this is just how we always did it
okay so the reason I gave Raymond that
line is because it only always works and
I'll tell you the story behind this so I
used to try and sell free trials and
believe it or not there was a time in my
life where I couldn't even get people
start free trials with me they literally
get in their car drive to my gym and i'
be like hey you want to 14-day free
trial and they would say yeah and I
think cool do you want to put you know
your credit card down and they'd be like
why do you need a credit card if it's a
free trial I'd be like I uh I mean it
well I know I didn't know it like cuz I
want to bill you later like you know
like I didn't have anything to say and
so one time it just came out and I was
like well this is just how we've always
done it and and after I started saying
that no one objected and so despite how
ridiculous that may sound it's
unbelievable how well it works so if
you're in one of the situations where
you have like a tiny little process
change or something that you need to do
or introduce you know into a sales
process like why are you collecting my
information now it's like oh that's just
how we've always done it and people just
know that a lot of employes just do what
they're told or they just do whatever
someone you know taught them to do it's
policy and so then what they do is they
just stop asking that person questions
cuz they're like it's not really up to
me it's it's just like oh this is how we
compete our our patient profiles okay
perfect like it's better to appeal to
policy totally they'll get this if this
for whatever reason ISS you you'll
you'll prioritize the insurance they'll
come in they're going to have the
printed out stack yeah of all the
insurance the doc gets this on a
clipboard yep right in order of the
patients that he sees that day um he's
like okay Mrs Johnson I've got your
X-ray here I've got your insurance here
okay this is what we're going to do for
you and then this prescriptive close
makes sense okay so right now are there
some locations that are having like way
higher close rates than others or like
what's the highest close rate probably I
would say Capitol Hill and uh what's the
difference though the docker has a lot
of certainty no no no uh percentage
difference oh um so let's say Auburn is
let's say they're averaging about 55 60%
okay and then uh Capital Hill might be
at like 80% okay no I mean they're both
okay you terrible yeah they're not
terrible but if you look at um cuz cuz a
lot of these people have insurance so
their entry level uh like Financial is
not like super high on so so the ones
that are just 10,000 case they have zero
out of pocket yeah so I mean you got
you're going to have 100% so kind of so
this is how I would so I would imagine
that the packages themselves are going
to be similar it's just how much is
being covered is going to be the
difference right yeah and then also the
fact that I think if if a clinic sees a
lot of those 100% coverage ones then
they kind of skip then they start they
don't work on their sales skills for the
ones that are and then they can say oh
these are crappy leads or shitty leads
or whatever yeah but just cuz you have
to work a little bit for them right so I
think just creating that training that's
that's how I'm you to train them and
role play more I'll give you something
that will help you a lot with brick and
mortar so I've done a lot of brick and
mortar sales processes in my life and um
as much as possible I like them to be
like clicks and check boxes when we sell
something for example it's like you
literally just turn a laptop around and
then you just like punch through it and
you literally just say the words and
then at the point that you ask for the
thing you ask for the like you really
can machine it that way yeah and that
will eliminate so much of the
variability between people and so I
would look at what the top 80% guy is
doing consistently make that into the
basically the deck so that they have a
visual aid to go through it and then it
just feels like oh this is this is the
next step I do this this is what you
need this is what we cover he circles
the thing on their on their thing turns
it to them and then they they they rock
and roll and then they just book out
their next appointments I'm assuming so
they're kind of looking at a tele proper
almost like okay but they can show it to
them okay so there's two ways to do it
one is you have the laptop and you turn
it towards the customer and then you
basically read the words on the slides
that is like the perfect sales pitch but
with visual aids and whatnot got it the
second way of doing it is you have that
clipboard M but they don't know what's
on the clipboard right and so the
clipboard just has the script got it and
so it's like cool I'm just ask a couple
questions and so you basically go
through the sales process and you just
look like you're checking off the boxes
as you're going through a script but
then they always say the script and then
the doc can visually showare this which
they then staple to the the patient
contract that way you know they follow
the process and then it just keeps it
consistent every time so either of those
work I've done them both okay so leads
page 207 if you have employees and you
want them to do what you want them to do
then there's three steps document you
make a checklist demonstrate you do it
in front of them duplicate they do it in
front of you and so right now the who's
actually doing it is that he wasn't the
the salesperson he did say he is good at
sales though and say okay I need you to
document this by putting this into a
checklist give it to someone else for
them to follow it so now that you have
it in a checklist now you follow it in
front of them so they can you prove that
the checklist works that and if you keep
changing things while you're not using
the checklist then keep changing the
checklist until you actually follow it
and then once you have the checklist
right have them followed in front of you
and then once that happens then you've
been able to duplicate the skill into
somebody else and that's going to be a
huge issue or rather a huge opportunity
for Raymond and his business so the next
one is
I think ad spend needs to go up so what
cuz you're not spending very much yeah I
know you know it wasn't until I had to
do this process I was like we can
because the return is so high on some of
those things and if I I mean I would
spend like a million dollars a month on
Google AdWords if I could yeah yeah so
how do we like I guess that would be one
thing to increase well the first thing I
would do is just literally tell them
like I need you to double the ad spend
and I need you to find more keywords so
just find more for me got it the other
thing that might be worth looking into
um would be uh local SEO okay because
SEO especially for intent based so it's
like obviously there search but it's not
hard to win at SEO locally like
nationally you want to win back pain
it's good luck but like you want to win
Everett you know chiropractor Everett
spine Everett pelvic Health Everett low
back ever lumbar ever like you mean
there's so many sciatic like all those I
think you could probably win on longtail
keywords so I'll put that as number
seven
um so right now Raymond is is doing the
core for so this is page 49 of the leads
book all right so this is about
advertising getting leads and so he is
currently running payad so one of the
core four but I think that he has an
opportunity on posting free content on
his site to drive SEO if you don't know
SEO is it's search engine optimization
so that people who have high intent who
are looking for a chiropractor in my
area or other keyword or longtail terms
will get sent to that site to maybe read
a blog arle or something that sounds
interesting and then while they're on
the site they can take one of the call
to actions in order to kind of take next
steps in the funnel and then one thing
that helps us on that I think is we're
pretty good about getting reviews we
have more reviews than everybody in our
cities oh that's great and then I think
that helps with the local SEO um but
yeah and the the I guess the big
question is like with the ad Spin A lot
of these so the agencies that we hire
like they work with uh many
chiropractors right so those most
chiropractors don't do what we do which
is sell packages of 2400 they do visit
to visit which is which is a nightmare
um so I think that they base our ads Ben
they're recommending our ads Ben based
on that but my return on is so much
higher than the average guy oh yeah so
then out spend everybody totally so if
you might have to talk in
um in marketer speak for them okay and
just give them this a Target CPA like
cost to acquire or CPL and just say like
listen I can I can pay up to this so
like Make It Rain dude if as long as
it's under this I'm good if you're
managing an agency the more specific you
can be the better and so you have to
kind of learn some marketing language so
that you can talk to them like marketers
and I also tell you they'll respect you
way more if you can speak their language
what you're going to be looking at is
either CAC depending on you know what
IND it's either CPA or CAC typically CPA
means cost per acquisition CAC is cost
you acquire a customer both terms
fundamentally mean the same thing and or
uh CPL so cost per lead I like to kind
of break this down into two numbers one
number is what I will tell them is my
acceptable range and then the number
that's actually my acceptable amount
because sometimes they tend to overshoot
this is just me with a history of
agencies and so I'll give I'll build in
a little bit of padding between what I
tell them and what I'm actually willing
to pay but the more you trust the agency
the more those two numbers can be closer
together because if you build trust
build a good relationship the higher up
that number is the more traffic they can
ultimately send you because they can
spend more to get you a customer and
would you have when would you consider
bringing that all in house um cuz I kind
of I hate dealing with these no I get it
I get it it probably wouldn't be my
priority right now cuz like if I look at
this I'm like okay we got 12 to1 24 to1
91 so I'm like we're doing pretty well
on this right um and do you not have do
you have Google on the other three as
well yeah okay it's just not there I
picked a one like a high middle low for
so that's low 9 to1 is a low one yeah
for sure oh that's great jeez okay cool
I would say basically I I'd stop it at 5
to one okay and say like so basically
double or triple whatever the CPA there
currently is and sometimes what you'll
find though is that if you can double or
even triple how much you can spend to
get a customer you might be able to like
10x lead flow it's not like it's not
it's not it's not proportional uh
because you just all of a sudden you
outs spend this many more people to to
illustrate that what what I'm explaining
to Raymond I'm going to give you two
hypothetical examples all right so let's
say I say you you could spend $11,000 in
scenario one and that'll turn into
$10,000 now you might think wow I should
do that but wait there's more what if I
said you could spend $10,000 and make
$50,000 which one would you rather have
well hopefully hopefully this one
because here you make $40,000 net and
here you make $9,000 despite the fact
that this is a 10:1 versus here you have
a 5 to1 so you have half the efficiency
but you have four and change times the
amount of absolute return and I see many
small business owners get stuck in this
trap of being like I have to optimize
this I have to optimize this and you do
to a degree but at some point sometimes
you just got to spend more you need to
expect efficiency to drop at scale it's
just part of the game cool so local SEO
add that in all right so let me do this
so what I want to do is I want to
reorder these okay um so that you have
kind of like next steps does that work
yeah okay sweet I feel like we can I
feel like we're making
profit I I like that pres I like the
doing it before this makes total SI dude
it's it's all it makes all the change in
the world so what I'm about to outline
is the next six months of work for
Raymond and I would say a relative
amount of increase that these tactics
can do for his business and so one of
the key parts of laying out a plan like
this is making sure that the person has
the right resources and that they're
doing them the right priorization order
right if there's something that takes 5
minutes and can double the business well
let's do that first and I tend to say
the heavier things for later unless it
it absolutely has to be done first and
the other ones are contingent on the
execution of that and so by and large I
will do light work high impact first and
then often times there's the heavy work
heavy impact that has other things that
tail or are attached to it as the order
of operations for him now we started
this whole conversation around
operations to make sure that they had
the right people in the right seats to
actually execute these strategies and so
that's also something I'm taking into
consideration when I'm laying out this
plan so I'm going to use black here so
we're going to
go
um in order so number one oh you're good
as
increase
Google spend so that's number one and
you're going to try and spend as much as
you possibly
can
Facebook wead
magnet $29 offer
three tighter ad copy what I would do
honestly is I would look at so this is
how I would how it how i' spy on some
so I would look for chiropractor
agencies that specialize in higher
ticket and then I would look at their
customers okay and then I would look at
their ad accounts and then I'll bet you
that they run the same ad copy that
seems to work really well for all of
them right and that's where I would look
at for if I was like if I had to do my
1.0 version okay so number four um this
is going to be the credit card plush
insurance
card uh
setter this is cool number F there
we go number five print out
morning of insurance plans six um we
need the sales manager to take over the
process right
manager
takes
sale one location test if it works well
you can roll it out yeah I already do
that oh perfect I got that right I would
add
in local
SEO to get more traffic this is a
long-term investment though but I think
it's so worth it for what you're trying
to do because the thing is SEO is going
to have the highest return yeah for sure
like in terms of Ro so to actually it be
more profitable it's just like you got
to be able to wait a year but you're
looking at a multi-year timeline so I
think it's just going to be worth it and
that's it's not worth doing that like
with all my individual locations yeah
you just ranking each of the yeah each
of those local markets and then like as
soon as you know you're going to open up
another one it's like you just yeah
exactly you start spinning it out I'll
just put a sub Point here same day God I
love that four
step
sale and we'll add
in sales preo SL checklist for integer
so I think if we do these things we put
a little estimator here I think this is
probably an easy 2X
in terms of lead flow and and making
more money this can absolutely double
the return that you're doing there this
kind of these two are together so I'll
just like mute there this is probably
going to give us the 10% back that we're
that we're losing between day one and
day two right now so this is plus 10%
now this one I think like the thing is
with this one that I like so much is it
like doubles the efficiency of each
store like this one's like super super
sexy because all of a sudden it might be
able to take your Kent from like 1.5 to
like three and like you might not have
to open any more stores like if you
could cuz like if you can double Revenue
the fixed costs are more or less the
same right and so if you doubled Revenue
across all of these then you'd already
be at five like you'd already be at five
in terms of Eva you wouldn't even have
to do anything else would that be
attracted to the insal Wi oh yeah even
small okay yeah got it yeah local SEO is
probably like you might be able to get
like a 30 to 50% boost okay it'll just
take like a year but it's the nice thing
is this all margin it's all margin and
then the sales pres will probably be ble
to smooth out your your closing
percentage probably be somewhere like a
20% lift that would be kind of like my
guess and so we've got a double a double
10% this could be a double depending
this is more in terms of volume right
volume this is uh yeah 30 to 50 and
probably 20% lift here and that's
probably about 6 months of
work well dude that's the plan thank you
so much dude 100% thank you man so I
just sat down with Alex and uh he broke
down my business and all the marketing
experience that we have and gave me some
pretty easy to implement things that we
can do to grow right way so Raymond was
amazing I'm so pumped to be able to work
with him in this business and help him
out here this was lots of fun for me
probably more fun for me than it even
was for him and hopefully even more fun
for you and if you like this style of
content really tactical business stuff
you're going to love the first one of
these that I did with Ashley who is a
stylist and I think the tactics I laid
out there could out many businesses blow
up